hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime opera and today i will be breaking
down the complete
tragic history of the todoroki family
including their origins all the shocking
family drama
and a crazy twist concerning shoto
todoroki's
other brother there is a lot to talk
about these guys are basically the
kardashians of mha
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going you know what to do leave a
quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps a lot with the youtube
algorithm
and if you're new to anime uproar or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications a huge thank you to all of
our anime upper
patrons who make videos like this one
possible i will talk more about patreon
at the end of the video but for now
please be advised that this video will
contain boku no hero manga spoilers
please proceed with caution you have
been warned
the todoroki family is an old respected
and prestigious family
and they appear to have been prestigious
even before angie became the family
patriarch
however as angie manifested an
incredibly strong flame quirk
and as he began climbing the top pro
hero charts
the prestige of the todorokis climbed
along with him
once it became clear that endeavour is
the top contender to one day replace
all might as the number one pro hero
other families began to see the
advantage
of forming a close alliance with the
todorokis
through marriage the himura family was
one
such family as we all know angie
todoroki aka
endeavor spent most of his life trying
to surpass all might
and failing miserably angie became so
frustrated by his inability to overtake
all might that he decided to set up a
quirk marriage with the
himura family the himuna family had a
daughter by the name of rey
and rey's father convinced her that she
should marry angie even though rey and
angie barely knew each other
and they certainly did not love each
other angie chose rey to be his wife not
out of love but because he believed that
her quirk was the perfect
pairing with his own quirk angie wanted
to produce a child with the ultimate
quirk a quirk that would one day
enable this child to fulfill angie's
dream of surpassing
all might because rey had a powerful
ice-based quirk and angie had a powerful
flame-based quirk
angie believed that the perfect
combination of these two quirks would
produce
the ultimate power for her part rey
agreed to the marriage out of a sense of
obligation to her family
this idea of a quirk marriage is a
fascinating concept and something that
is unique to the world of boku no
hero the obvious analogy to this in our
own world would be political marriages
where two families join together
in order to increase their wealth and
influence regardless of whether the two
people getting married
actually want to be together the
marriage itself is not about love it is
about
interest similarly a quirk marriage is
also about interest but the focus is on
creating offspring with the best
possible quirks
i think that this quirk marriage concept
is a good addition to the story because
realistically if quirks were real in our
own world
this type of marriage would probably be
a thing it just feels real
and plausible within the context of that
world and of course
this type of marriage comes with its own
unique set of challenges
and hardships after their marriage angie
and rey
would have four children together the
eldest was a son
named toya who inherited angie's
flame-based quirk abilities
then they had a daughter named fuyumi
who inherited her mother's ice-based
quirk
and after that they had natsuol who also
inherited his mother's ice-based powers
finally they had shoto who as we know
was born with the perfect combination of
both fire
and ice the overpowered quirk known as
have hot half cold shoto's quirk is
exactly the type of power that angie had
in mind when he first embarked upon
this quirk marriage and so once shoto's
powers manifested
angie decided to turn shoto into the
hero who would one day surpass
all might angie separated shoto from his
siblings
and forced him to undergo rigorous
training and
in his obsession to turn shoto into the
future number one pro hero
angie neglected the rest of his children
that is the story we all know
and we've known it for quite a while but
that is not the whole story not even
close
in the more recent arcs of the manga we
learned a lot more about the todoroki
family
and especially about shoto's mysterious
older brother
toya and even though i already gave you
all a spoiler warning at the beginning
of this video
i will now warn everyone one more time
that major spoilers
are ahead angie and rey's eldest santoya
was actually born with an incredibly
strong
flame based quirk even though it was not
the epic combination of fire and ice
that shoto possesses
angie readily acknowledged that his son
toya's quirk was even stronger than his
own
and so angie believed that toya did
indeed have the potential to surpass
all might but if that is the case why
did ng focus all of his attention on
shoto while neglecting toya even though
toya had the potential to achieve
exactly what ng wanted the answer lies
in the specific way
in which ngs and rey's quirks combined
within
toya although he inherited his father's
flame-based quirk
and although toya's flame quirk was
actually even stronger than angie's
toya's body did not develop a sufficient
resistance
to fire instead his body inherited his
mother's ability to tolerate
extreme cold but not his father's
ability to tolerate
extreme heat as a result every time
toya used his flame based quirk he
burned his own body
and injured himself even after noticing
this dangerous side effect
angie still believed that toya could be
the one to surpass
all might but after rey and the other
children expressed their concerns that
toya's training is slowly killing him
anji finally agreed that toya cannot be
the one to surpass
all might angie made this decision not
because he didn't like toya or because
he didn't believe in him
he made the decision because he actually
cared about toya
in his own strange way and he didn't
want his son to keep getting
hurt however by that point toya already
had his heart set
on becoming the future number one pro
hero and surpassing all might
angie had already awakened that dream
within him and toyah didn't want to give
up on his live stream
just because using his quirk burned his
own body a little toyah wanted to keep
training he wanted to keep getting
stronger and he wanted to make his
father
proud and so toyah kept coming home with
burns and bruises because he kept up his
training in secret
he clearly wasn't getting the message so
angie decided to try a tougher approach
angie told toya straight up to give up
on his dream of being a hero
and just focus on other things like his
sister fuyumi and his brother natsuo
were
already doing angie said this for toya's
own
good if toya gives up on being a hero
then he won't have to deal with a
lifetime of agony as he is forced to
burn himself
over and over again just so he could use
his quirk but
when his own father forced him to give
up on his dream
toya was crushed it made him feel
inadequate and worthless
and it made him jealous of his younger
brother shoto shoto was the one whom
angie was focusing on now
and this was extremely painful for toya
because he still wanted to be the one to
make his father's dream come true
eventually all this disappointment and
frustration led to toya losing it
desperate to get his father's attention
and to regain his favor
toya blew up in his family and tried to
hurt baby shoto
this is the point in which angie decided
to separate shoto from the other
children
and just train him in isolation he did
this to protect
shoto from another potential attack by
toyah but
all this did was isolate choto from the
rest of his family while also making
toya
even more upset since ng now spent most
of his time alone with shoto
the other children felt neglected by
their father and this was especially the
case with toyah and just as ng had been
obsessed with surpassing
all might for years toya became obsessed
with achieving his father's dream
even if his father wouldn't help him
anymore at this point
toya seems to have concluded that
mastering his quirk and becoming a hero
is his singular purpose in life and so
he continued to train in secret
until his flames eventually changed from
red
to blue during his training toya also
realized that the power of his flames
is directly connected to his emotions
after his flames changed color toya
regained a bit of his confidence and he
decided to show his new power
to his father he invited angie to come
to a remote location known as secuto
hill
during the holiday break because he
wanted to show his father that his
flames are now blue and even more
powerful than they were before
but angie decided not to go to secure
hill
at the scheduled time he believed that
if he showed up he would be encouraging
his son to keep hurting himself
and so he decided not to go in the hopes
that this would finally convince toyah
to give up
on being a hero while sitting alone up
on secure hill
toya is consumed with disappointment and
he begins to cry
after being rejected by his father yet
again he becomes
intensely emotional and because his
quirk is directly connected to his
emotions toya's entire body
suddenly bursts into flames toya loses
control of his own flames
and this leads to a massive fire that
scorches the entire hill
a fragment of toya's jawbone was later
found on the
scene and toyah was presumed to have
died in the flames
angie and rey's eldest son was dead and
angie's neglect and
harsh parenting style were partially to
blame for this
tragic loss but instead of learning from
his mistakes
the tragedy drove angie even deeper into
his
obsession in an attempt to take his mind
off of toya
and his own sense of guilt ng doubled
down on training shoto to one day
surpass
all might and of course this led to an
even greater divide within the todoroki
family
eventually rey's mental health
deteriorated she simply could not cope
with the loss of her son
and the cruelty of her husband at the
same time and
she snapped one day while she was
talking on the phone
she was surprised by the sudden
appearance of a young shoto
the left side of shoto's face triggered
a traumatic episode because it reminded
rey so much of angie and she then
proceeded to throw boiling water at
choto
permanently scarring his face as soon as
the incident occurred
rey immediately regretted it she didn't
do this intentionally she was not in her
right state of mind
and after the incident happened rey
tried her best to care for shoto's wound
but the damage was already done and rey
was ultimately committed to a mental
institution
for his part shoto did not blame his
mother
for what happened he blamed his father
for traumatizing his mother to the
extent that she became
mentally unstable as we know shoto's
resentment for his father would continue
for years
and at the beginning of the series shoto
still hated his father so much that he
refused to use the flame side of his
quirk
shoto's brother natsuo also felt a
similar type of resentment for enji
while their sister fuyumi seems to have
been a bit more moderate
in that regard and yet the tragic story
of the todoroki family
is still not over as we find
out later on in the story toya todoroki
did not
really die in that fire on secure hill
although he was presumed dead he somehow
survived
and about a decade later he reappeared
as the ruthless
villain dobby we don't know where he
went
or how he came to be a villain but once
he did become
dobby toya morphed into a completely
different
person far from wanting to be a hero and
surpass
all might he wanted to destroy the
corrupt hero society
and he had no problem with murdering
people along the way
just like angie was driven by obsession
for most of his life dobby
is also a man completely consumed by
obsession
and while angie's obsession was to
surpass all might
dabi is obsessed with getting revenge on
his father
the man he came to blame for everything
that happened to him
dobby is so determined to destroy his
father and make his father
suffer that he is even willing to kill
his own brother shoto
if the opportunity ever arises and he
wants to do this
just so he could see the look on angie's
face when his golden boy dies
naturally the shocking revelation that
the villain dobby was
toyah all along rocks the entire
todoroki family
to their core and as of the making of
this video
they are still trying to come to terms
with that earth-shattering reveal
i have to say this really is some
top-tier family drama
and i can't wait to see what happens
next and
that is it the complete history of the
todoroki family
explained what do you guys think of the
kardashians of the boku no hero world
and what do you think will happen with
dobby in the end let me know
down in the comments if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more boku no
hero content in the future just leave a
like it only takes a second but it helps
a lot
and if you're new to animeopro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting the
option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to
alpha sigma he is an absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
water the toasted chi the spike emperor
otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist cody
hebert and monkey d
quilly finally thank you also to our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only gilgamesh the red-haired raven
angel cruz rathundera very gucci alicia
octor bonnie parks joy and garcia ted no
ted fat boy games corey mcgowan and soul
ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time
see face cowboys
[Music]
you